Welcome back everyone this is my new doctor
strange 2 multiverse of madness x-men video
there's a big report that's been circulating about
x-men coming into the mcu so we'll break it all
down there's a bunch of really cool multiverse
easter eggs especially given the crazy multiverse
crossover stuff we saw just happened in the
spiderman no way home trailer so if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos it's only going to get crazier and crazier
for the rest of this year but we all just saw
the spiderman no way home trailer a billion times
with all the tobey maguire spider-man and andrew
garfield spider-man movie easter eggs and sinister
six villains showing up from the multiverse or
spider-verse i guess we should say because it is
a spider-man movie so we already know marvel's
crossing over big movie franchises from other
studios in the sony spider-man movies it shouldn't
be any big surprise then that recently several
websites reported news that marvel would be using
doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness to bring
some fox x-men characters into the mcu proper or
should we say the marvel cinematic multiverse now
and it's not deadpool because we already knew that
deadpool was coming to the mcu they are making
deadpool 3 right now it's going to be a mcu movie
even though it will be rated r and ryan reynolds
just did that big deadpool and korg video which he
said had to go through like 10 levels of approvals
at marvel so it's already kind of canon to the mcu
any tips on uh getting into the mcu there cork uh
have a dream uh chase it lose that dream just
sabotage all sorts of happiness in pursuit of
that dream climb up to the peaks of that mountain
and when you get to the top land at the bottom
and realize you're never going to achieve that
dream and at that point check your emails maybe
you'll get something from your agent saying
marvel wants to talk yeah i prefer dark world
half a penny of you for this but apparently this
x-men stuff is supposed to be a really big deal
in doctor strange 2 the same people who were
reporting that scarlet witch would be kind of
a fake-out villain for part of the movie kind of
an antagonist we're also reporting that during the
movie at some point scarlet witch is going to
be fighting a major a-list fox x-men character
an x-men character who's powerful enough to hold
their own against someone as op as scarlet witch
has become by the end of Wandavision when she
went full-blown scarlet witch learning about
how her chaos magic abilities worked but now on
top of all the stuff that happened to her all the
big upgrades she got during wandavision she also
now has one of the most powerful books of magic
in the universe and she's on the loose trying
to find a way to bring her children back
thinking that they're trapped in some other part
of the multiverse so when all these websites were
reporting that she'd be fighting one of the
biggest fox x-men characters they also claimed
that originally marvel and kevin feige had tried
to get hugh jackman to come back as his wolverine
and be the character that she'd fight but for
scheduling reasons maybe some other reasons it
just didn't work out so if you saw a bunch of
people talking about hugh jackman almost being
in doctor strange 2 that's probably what they were
referring to a little while ago hugh jackman was
also talking about this too he claimed that kevin
feige had not contacted him about coming back for
any kind of cameo as his version of wolverine
which i thought was just a fake out like actors
say that all the time i don't know what you're
talking about if you remember all the lies
that the russos told about avengers end game at
avengers infinity war all the other marvel actors
told about those movies it's the same situation
now you have to take everything that any actor or
any producer director says with a grain of salt
but apparently just based on all these reports
about x-men crossover the character that marvel
wound up bringing back is supposed to be james
mcavoy's professor x i believe which if it's true
makes sense that they would go for a character
like him amongst the top tier most powerful x-men
characters capable of handling or dealing with
scarlet witch professor x would be one of your go
to's because even though gene grey phoenix is more
powerful i wasn't a huge fan of the sophie turner
version of that character and the whole idea
in the mcu especially in Wandavision is that
despite all the bad crap that scarlet witch pulls
totally going off the rails holding a whole town
hostage for an entire week against their will
pretty much torturing them for a whole week she's
not actually supposed to be a villain in the mcu
so if she does wind up being an antagonist for
part of the plot of doctor strange 2 is only
because she's steamrolling everyone with the dark
hole trying to stop her from trying to find her
children and bring them back like the dark hole is
supposed to be so dangerous there's no way doctor
strange or the other heroes wouldn't try to stop
her not because they hate her just for her own
good in the sake of the main mcu reality because
theoretically she would mess it up even worse than
what spider-man and doctor strange did to the main
mcu reality during spider-man no way home you have
to imagine doctor strange having all these ptsd
flashbacks to spiderman no way home when he learns
that she has the dark hole like oh no i just went
through this with peter parker we can't do this
again and if we're saying that scarlet witch
is supposed to be one of the most powerful mcu
characters right now just in terms of magic they
claim during Wandavision that she's supposed to be
more powerful than the sorcerer's supreme so in a
magic on magic fight it sounds like doctor strange
wouldn't be able to overpower her especially
when she has the dark hold so how do you fight
a character that's that powerful you use a psychic
attack and that does seem like it's one of scarlet
witch's trademark weaknesses in the comics is her
psyche so that's why you would go to someone like
professor x the most powerful telepath on the
planet or at least in some universes but if it
wasn't clear the whole stakes for wanda during the
movie were made pretty clear in that Wandavision
post credit scene it tells you everything you
need to know about why she's messing with the
multiverse she's looking for a way to bring her
children back now whether or not billy and tommy's
cries were real or a fake-out plan engineered by
the real main villain of the movie remains to be
seen but it does seem like the actors who play
billy and tommy are actually in doctor strange
2 and will appear so they're going to pay that off
and kevin feige did say that doctor strange 2 will
not be the end of scarlet witch's character in mcu
movies like she'll continue to show up in future
mcu movies and be an even bigger deal and during
all my Wandavision videos earlier this year i
already talked a lot about how they're setting up
young avengers in the future of the mcu with older
versions of some of these characters like an older
version of billy and tommy at some point so doctor
strange 2 is just another step along that path but
the bigger idea here though is that marvel's using
all this multiverse craziness through spiderman
no way home and now doctor strange 2 to bring in
more of the fox x-men characters to the mcu proper
i know a lot of you were hoping for some magneto
like daddy shows up because of all the scarlet
witch comic book history in the whole quicksilver
of it all with their big mandarin level fake out
with evan peters on wandavision bringing even just
james mcavoy from those core x-men movies into the
mcu is enough to say that all the fox x-men movies
are now canon to the mcu through the multiverse
that's why i keep saying that you should also kind
of think of the mcu as the marvel cinematic
multiverse where all these other franchises
like the tobey maguire spider-man movies andrew
garfield spider-man movies even the venom movies
the fox fantastic four movies now the fox x-men
movies all become canon is alternate universes
as part of the larger mcu multiverse even though
deadpool was already kind of going to canonize all
the fox x-men movies in the mcu when he showed up
in a new mcu movie it just seems now like doctor
strange 2 will beat him to that punch they kind
of did a version of this during x-men days of
future past but it was a little bit different the
way they canonized all the x-men movies together
during that movie they crossed over the younger
first-class versions of the characters with the
original x-men movie actors but in that movie they
were just saying that the original movie versions
like patrick stewart professor x was the older
version of james mcavoy's professor x because
all the first class movies took place in the past
whereas now in doctor strange 2 spider-man no way
home these movies are saying that all these other
franchises just took place in alternate universes
alternate timelines which are kind of the same
thing almost in the mcu like classic deadpool joke
these timelines are so confusing and it's only
going to get crazier from here just to explain the
whole evan peters quicksilver on Wandavision of it
all the reason why he got quicksilver's powers and
they look like the x-men quicksilver super speed
powers is because of the enchantment that agatha
harkness put on him with the necklace he lost his
powers once monica rambo ripped it off in the way
the producers explained his character the main
mcu universe ralph here just happened to look
like pietro from the fox x-men universe and
the producers used the visualization of fox
quicksilver's powers to mess with the viewers even
more to add more doubt as to who he really was and
how he could exist but evan peters did say that he
would love to come back as actual quicksilver at
some point i'm thrilled i'm such a huge fan of the
marvel universe so i'm like i'm just excited to be
here pietro but he looks different because it's
evan peters and an interesting way to do it like
when kevin was telling me about it i was like oh
that sounds awesome and hilarious it's so weird so
all this multiverse craziness is just one of the
ways marvel is introducing x-men and mutants into
the mcu i just did a big eternals trailer video
about how that movie is one of the other different
ways that they're setting up mutants in the mcu so
i'll add a link for that at the end of this video
and down in the description so we will start
seeing different types of x-men characters and
mutants showing up all over the place in the next
few years before they do their next big solo x-men
movie inside the mcu and based on their current
release schedule it sounds like that's going to
wind up happening around the time that they're
doing avengers 5. the way kevin feige explained
their plans for that is that they want to explain
some of the bigger questions about who's going to
be on that next big team the next big avengers
team who's going to finance it and if you've
been following the marvel movies and you've kind
of been looking at the clues behind the scenes i
think those answers are pretty clear for instance
the next richest person in the mcu capable of
financing the avengers which costs billions of
dollars based on all the technology that they use
would be the royal family of wakanda i would
say black panther but obviously there's a big
transition happening and we're gonna find out who
the new black panther will be after black panther
2 wakanda forever but everybody let me know in the
comments what do you think about x-men showing up
during doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness even
if it's a small character i won't care it'll still
be super cool speaking of doctor strange my full
marvel what if episode 4 video will post wednesday
that'll be the dark doctor strange episode so
be sure to enable alerts for my channel so you
don't miss that while you wait for everything
click here for my full spider-man no way home
trailer video and click here for that brand
new black panther 2 wakanda forever first look
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you in the next one!